dear friends
i thank the rrr team for this invitation
the european commission's union of
equality work provides particular
attention to intersectional minority
identities and the multiple
discrimination that persons belonging to
such groups often experience
of course this is also true for roma
lgbtiq persons indeed the commission has
firmly anchored these issues in the
reformed eu roma strategic framework and
the first eu lgbt iq equality strategy
since the beginning of my mandate i have
made sure that the commission implements
its equality strategies using
intersectionality
as a cross-cutting principle for
instance the eu-roma strategic framework
encourages an intersectional approach in
view of the fact that on occasions
discrimination on the grounds of ethnic
origin is compounded with discrimination
on other aspects of identity
it explicitly calls on the member states
to focus more on diversity among roma by
ensuring that national strategic
frameworks meet the specific needs of
different groups including the roma
lgbtiq community
i continue to work closely with member
states to foster acknowledgement that
discrimination is often compounded and
is an aspect that needs to be addressed
in the national strategies
and it must be addressed properly
but as you are likely to discuss today
we need to invest more in research and
targeted awareness raising about the
impact of multiple discrimination on
individuals
i am therefore very interested to hear
your recommendations on how we can best
reflect the challenges and concrete
policies and laws
close-up cooperation and open dialogue
with civil society organizations is an
essential part of our work and i always
make sure that civil society
organizations participate to the design
implementation and monitoring of our
equality policies
the commission will also continue to
provide funding to support civil society
organizations under the
2021-2027 citizens equality rights and
values program
supporting projects like yours is
crucial because they contribute greatly
to reaching our larger political goal of
a union of equality where we can ensure
safety integrity and equal opportunities
for all eu citizens